today we're answering a simple question
that's been lingering in my head for a
while now what is a God in the MCU yeah
it shouldn't be too hard right I am a
god you dull creature okay so Loki is a
god they are not Gods we're born we live
we die okay so as Guardians are not gods
someone might want to give that memo to
Loki gotta suggest
so as Guardians our Gods the humans
think are Immortal should we test that
oh come on
thank you
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the show that's genetically engineered
to click that subscribe button well
loyal theorists after what could
charitably be called a complicated
series of delays Guardians the Galaxy
vol 3 is finally here to help Marvel
Studios kick off the beginning of phase
five surprised to see me no nope you get
out of here Modoc you had your chance
yeah so despite a challenging few years
for Marvel Studios they got a
desperately needed win with guardians
the Galaxy vol 3 allowing writer
director James Gunn to finish out his
story with these characters with a
genuinely heartfelt film before he jumps
over to his new job running Marvel's
main rival DC Studios fun fact by the
way Gunn was originally positioned to be
sort of a mini Kevin feige at Marvel
running the entire Cosmic side of their
Universe before Disney temporarily fired
him on account of some old controversial
tweets thereby allowing DC to swoop in
and scoop him up that drama resulted in
the new Guardians movie dropping three
years after it was originally intended
to release which means that there's a
timeline out there in the Multiverse
where end game would have been followed
by Spider-Man far from home and then
Guardians 3. it doesn't take a theorist
brain to realize that firing gun might
just have been one of the biggest
unforced errors in cinema history that
right there that's a discussion for
another day no what I want to talk about
today is actually a question that I've
seen floating around the internet for a
while now what even is a God in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe these days
between the asgardians the celestials
multiversal time travelers beings that
seem to exist outside universes it's not
really clear what a God is anymore and
now in this most recent Guardians film
you have the main bad guy the high
evolutionary who's explicitly called out
to be Godlike characters mentioned that
several parts of the Galaxy consider him
to be a God the golden people from
Guardians 2 The Sovereign they were
created by Him and they treat him as
their God even the high evolutionary
himself straight up screams his thoughts
on the matter at us with the very subtle
line there is no God that's why I had to
step in but for as on the noses that
line is is he wrong I mean he did create
life after all so is he or is he not a
god at this point I'm not really sure if
Marvel themselves know the answer you
know that's kind of a big deal when
several of your latest films revolve
around the god-tier characters heck the
entire plot of Thor love and thunder was
about a villain who wanted to kill all
gods maybe the audience should have
known what a God was before they ran
with that story huh this is My Vow oh
God she won't die hey if you manage to
figure out who's on that list Gore more
power to ya you kinda earned it at that
point so if Marvel isn't gonna answer
the question in their movies I thought
we'd take a crack at it loyal theorists
what exactly is a God in the MCU are
there any actual gods in the MCU well I
think I found the answer in a couple of
places you might never imagine so open
the freaking door and hop on in loyal
theorists it's time to get rolling when
you start breaking the question down you
start to see some key groups forming the
characters of stuff like Greek Norse and
Egyptian mythology these tend to be very
powerful beings who hold domains over
one specific aspect of the universe it
can either be tangible measurable stuff
like the moon or thunder or more
intangible Concepts like War Mischief
the MCU has these sorts of characters in
Spades as it seems like most major
religions throughout the history of
Earth are based on them Thor Loki Odin
all the other asgardians their
picture-perfect examples of this as are
the Olympians that we met during love
and thunder like Zeus and Hercules
there's the Egyptian gods of Moon Knight
as well as Namor from wakanda Forever
who acts as a representative of
Mesoamerican Gods even characters like
the eternals seem to fit into this
category because apparently several of
Earth's myths were based on their lives
Humanity once believed we were Gods the
flying Superman Icarus evolved into the
legend of the boy who flew too close to
the Sun the legendary Warrior thina
became Athena the goddess of wisdom and
warfare
Eternal the legendary protector of
Athens the goddess of war and yet even
at this lowest tier of godhood things
get confusing in a hurry spriting the
eternals claims that the Greek goddess
Athena was inspired by Athena but then
we see the Roman deity Minerva wandering
around omnipotent City in love and
thunder Minerva is the Roman version
vision of Athena she's the same goddess
she just has a different name how's that
work and in general the rest of the
omnipotent crew are inconsistent in the
way that they choose to manifest
sometimes these characters are real
physical beings that exist in the
material universe who can feel pain and
die they are not Gods we're born we live
we die just as humans do other times
they need people in order to harness
their power where Gods like konshu and
Moon Knight and Boston black panther
have to act through a human
representative what are you I serve
can't you I'm his Avatar which means you
are too sort of conscious yeah Egyptian
god of the Moon that's the stupidest
thing I've ever heard sort of like an
avatar system avatars do people love
that film by Avatar you mean that I mean
anime and while the human Avatar can die
the God remains and the only way to get
rid of them is to imprison them in
little Idols for thousands of years in
every single one of these cases they all
seem to just be highly Advanced
creatures that are lowly human meat
brains confuse for Gods Jane Foster
really sums this up best in Thor one
well Magic's just science that we don't
understand stand yet in general these
groups are classified as Gods by the
humans in the MCU but they're not actual
Gods well sure sometimes they'll call
themselves Gods like Loki and Avengers
or hella in Ragnarok that's just them
flexing their might relative to Their
audience when push truly comes to shove
and when they're honest with themselves
they know deep down that they're not
actual Gods you're not a god
you know that right as Guardians and
Olympians are basically just long-lived
very human-looking aliens Namor is just
a mutant the eternals are weird flesh
robots the closest thing I think we have
to actual gods in this category are the
Egyptian Pantheon because they do seem
to have some outright control over souls
and afterlives but even then I'm not
convinced that they don't have
themselves a physical form hidden out
there somewhere in the MCU that can
eventually be killed for instance we
know Bost from Black Panther has control
over the afterlife and acts through a
human Avatar just like kanchu in Moon
Knight and yet we also see her physical
form manifested in omnipotent City
during Thor 11 Thunder she's there
hanging out with a bunch of other
powerful But ultimately killable beings
because of that I think we can
confidently conclude that none of these
characters are actually Gods they're
just super powerful mortal beings so
what's next then well the second
archetype that I can think here is your
classic creators characters who are said
to have crafted entire worlds simply
because they wanted to interestingly the
high evolutionary thinks that he fits
into this category having created
creatures like rocket and The Sovereign
but when you actually stop and look at
who else is here seems like Herbert
might be a bit out of his League it's
here that you find characters like the
celestials those giant alien robot gods
that use Infinity Stones like they're
nothing
into planets Across the Universe ego The
Living Planet from Guardians 2 a
Celestial literally wanted to transform
every planet he visited into another
version of himself the other celestials
they've just been seeding worlds with
life in an effort to get themselves to
reproduce there's also dormammu the big
bad evil guy from the first Doctor
Strange he's ruler of the dark dimension
he eats realities to combine them with
himself seems awfully Godlike and when
Galactus is eventually added to the
universe in the Fantastic Four movie I'd
expect him to fall into this category as
well but here's the thing these guys
aren't really Gods either and again we
know this based on their own admission
and what's called a Celestial sweetheart
a Celestial like a god small Jesus well
to lesser beings these creatures would
be considered gods again they recognize
that there are higher Powers than even
themselves they live they have a need to
reproduce and they can die if you kill
me you'll be just like everybody else
the Guardians team spends a lot of time
in nowhere which is the head of yet
another dead Celestial as for dormammu
we see that he's able to be be affected
by the Infinity Stones which suggests
that he's Bound by the physical
limitations of the world as ego says if
I don't return regularly to my planet
and The Light Within it this form will
wither and perish the celestials and or
Mamu are powerful and are certainly more
powerful than the base level of gods
that we talked about before but they're
only one rung up on this overall power
totem pole what about something more
metaphysical characters that exist more
like ideas who are said to have created
literally everything in existence in the
context of the MCU we've only really met
one of these so far the cosmic being
eternity in Thor love and thunder who
had the ability to literally alter
Reality by granting any wish put before
it eternity what does he mean root
eternity eternity is a very powerful
being at the center of the universe it
will grant the desire of the first
person who reaches it based on the
statues that we see at eternity's altar
there are at least seven of these sorts
of entities in the universe altering
entire universes on a whim seems like
something a true God could do right well
yeah in reality but in the MCU it's not
quite Godlike enough look at Kang and
his variants they've spent eons going
throughout the Multiverse erasing entire
realities and presumably those realities
versions of Eternity and the other gods
sure in love and thunder Gore's problem
is ultimately solved by making a wish to
Eternity but it seems like it could also
have been solved by just finding another
reality where his daughter didn't die
implying to me that eternity is limited
to a single Universe listen again to
where they have to find eternity in love
and thunder the center of the universe
not the center of the Multiverse so is
Kang then the one in control of the
Multiverse a god nope I don't think you
can really call any of the Kang variants
Gods either he who remains gets killed
in his first appearance Kang the
Conqueror gets defeated by large ants
not very impressive for a God so even
though they have the most multiversal
power of any of the Creations we've seen
yet even they aren't at the top of this
Heap honestly when you look up and down
the whole hierarchy of power here in the
MCU none of the characters we meet
really seem to match up with the true
idea of what a God should be in one way
or another something always cancels them
out something can destroy them something
can make them mortal and if we'd gone
into this Theory a year ago I'd leave it
there there are no true gods in the MCU
because ultimately there is no higher
power but I'm not convinced that that's
the case anymore one of the most
heart-wrenching scenes in Guardians
volume 3 sees rocket raccoon's
Consciousness wake up in a misty white
room it's here that he speaks with the
spirits of his lost friends they tell
him that they're flying through the
Forever Sky and that he's welcome to
join them but just not yet rocket still
has a purpose in the world rockathan
asks a purpose for what they made us for
nothing and his friend disagrees saying
there are the hands that make us and
then there are the hands that guide the
hands now this could all just be
happening in Rocket's head this could
just be the brain of a dying animal
trying to make sense of their life a
dramatic moment to add weight to a
climactic scene but to me I think this
confirms that the MCU has an afterlife
one beyond the astral Plains of black
panther one beyond the field of reeds
and Moon Knight this feels like absolute
confirmation that there is some sort of
all-powerful force the hands behind the
hands a god figure running everything
behind the scenes and you won't believe
where we really get that answer from
Kevin it stands for knowledge
one who's making all the decisions here
yeah I gotta be honest with you I didn't
really expect to get a whole lot of
universe altering Knowledge from
She-Hulk attorney at law but I think
Kevin here this robot insert from Marvel
Studios head honcho Kevin feige is
literally one of if not the only true
God one of the canonical creators of
this universe firstly this is how Marvel
has tended to do it in the past several
times throughout Marvel's 60 plus year
comic run many of their characters have
encountered a being simply known as the
one above all he most famously met the
Fantastic Four using the form of a man
who looked an awful lot like Jack Kirby
man who channeled his immense power
through something that looked an awful
lot like a pencil now If You Don't Know
Jack Kirby was the comic book writer and
artist who had just as much of a hand in
the creation of the Marvel universe as
Stan Lee did if not more he co-created
dozens of the most popular characters
Captain America Fantastic Four the X-Men
black panther Thor the eternals the
celestials just to name a few the choice
to depict the one above all is Jack
Kirby and his power as a pencil was not
only a sign of respect towards him but
also it was just accurate he was the one
calling the shot he was the one deciding
who lived and who died he was the one
creating the rules of this universe but
now we're in the MCU and the hands that
guide the hands it's not the creators
anymore it's the Kevins of the world in
James Gunn's original vision of the
Guardians Trilogy the original Gamora
was never set to die she had to die
because the hands that guide the hands
dictated that it had to happen in
Infinity War now think about what they
have to say to rocket in the new movie
you have more purpose here I suspect if
this was just James Gunn's story if he
were truly the God of this world
Rocket's narrative would have ended here
but the true Gods the Kevins or whoever
is above him they're the ones deciding
that rocket has more franchise potential
he has more to do his narrative isn't
over and so he must live on now you
might love that this is a really meta
answer or you might absolutely hate it
I'm just here to tell you what the films
themselves are saying or at least what I
suspect James Gunn here seems to be
saying in Guardians the Galaxy 3. I feel
like a lot of this is actually just
commentary for him having to deal with a
killed off Gamora but maybe I'm just
reading too much into it that said there
is one force that even more powerful
than Kevin and that's us you the
audience in a lot of ways we are the
real gods of the MCU here as long as we
keep watching the movies the characters
will continue to live on and once we
stop watching well that's when the
Kevins of the world start to panic it
was our indifference and disappointment
towards phase four that got Kevin to
slow down releases at the end of the day
the Kevins of the world are ultimately
serving us and we are in the position of
power deciding whether or not we approve
of the offerings they give they toil so
we can consume and if that's not a
Godlike relationship I don't know what
is so while they might be the hands that
are guiding the hands we are the eyes
watching it all happen deciding whether
or not we approve of their work here's
the moral of the story friends and you
best listen up Marvel if you can't
answer important questions about your
own Universe if you keep putting out
stories that no one wants if you can't
get your act together and actually put
out films that have heart and soul the
audience is going to lose interest
they're gonna leave these characters
behind for something better and the
likes of Star-Lord and Captain America
and Iron Man all of them will join the
ranks of the Pantheon's long past
stories we remember but ones we just
don't tell anymore but hey that's just a
theory a film Theory and cut
foreign